[Musique]
c'est un slogan pédagogique lancé par le
gouvernement dans la lutte contre le
coronavirus dedans avec les miens dehors
en citoyen sept mots pour inciter les
français à ne pas recevoir chez eux ou
aller chez les autres pour favoriser
aussi le télétravail et les gestes
barrières comme l'aération de son
logement tout en respectant le
couvre-feu instauré à 19h dedans avec
les miens
dehors un citoyen et rendez vous à la
saint glinglin
c'est ce qui se passe à la cia que je
n'arrive pas comment vous dites série de
mesures ridicules et sa phase et c'est
vraiment on ennuie en vain non ce qui me
manque encore de dire qu'on tape sur
gouvernement est ce qu'il ya des hommes
politiques plus faciles à caricaturer
que d'autres oui oui castex et bien pour
le peu que j'allais pouvoir
il a un vrai potentiel après les gens
disent ah mais c'est si timide saxons on
sait que la situation elle est encore
une fois douloureuse pour chacun des
français allait d'abord douloureuse pour
ceux qui ont perdu la vie pour leurs
familles douloureuse pour ceux qui ont
perdu la vie moi je veux pas être
toujours en train de critiquer certains
commençaient à tomber sur il ya eu
défaite qui ont été organisées tous les
médias se sont affolés en disant il ya
eu des rave parties par exemple aux gens
vous allez voir ça va exploser et
derrière il n'y a pas eu grand chose
parce que c'est fait en plein air alors
moi j'ai du mal à comprendre si c'est
dangereux ou pas ce qui s'est passé à
marseille un docteur à sable ok ben on
aura la réponse est à suivre samedi sur
ses origines super mais l'histoire des
dîners parisiens pour tout le monde
triche tout le monde triche toulon fait
des dîners tout le monde passe ne couvre
souhait de ça quand je dis tout le monde
me met pas dedans parce que pour le coup
je fais pas de dîner ne songez pas
d'amis donc personne viendra mais les
voraces
non w enfin une voiture s'arrête tous
beaux tous mes gars à cannes où quand on
dit aux fruits
vachon au maire
la cdu relance dit c'est moi c'est une
rencontre plutôt inhabituel faut bien
l'avouer en roumanie un ours s'est
invité sur la piste de ski alors que des
skieurs prenait tout simplement leur
cours avec un moniteur il s'est mis à
les suivre sur plusieurs centaines de
mètres
de quoi tester leur sang-froid
clairement les gars ont réussi
finalement à le sommer l'animal a trouvé
refuge dans la forêt une séance photo
qui tourne mal regardé ces images
tournées ce matin dans le centre ville
d'al trois taureaux se sont échappés des
arènes de ont été rapidement capturés
mais le troisième s'est enfui et a
blessé une femme de 69 ans elle a été
transportée à l'hôpital pour un
traumatisme à l'épaule il a fallu
utiliser un drone pour localiser
l'animal direction taïwan où plus de 150
habitants ont changé de nom pour
intégrer le mot saumon à leur patronyme
car sur présentation de leur carte
d'identité qu'ils exposent fièrement sur
les réseaux sociaux
les princes saumon et autres rois
météores saumons ont bénéficié d'une
promotion dans une chaîne de restaurants
sushi gratuit à volonté pour eux et cinq
invités si l'offre a eu tant de succès
c'est aussi parce que changer de nom à
taïwan est possible trois fois et cela
ne coûte que 2 euros
alors je ne connais pas les prénoms de
toutes les miss france mais vous je le
connais parce que mes six enfants et
moi-même nous avons voté pour
c'est vrai ça va coûter très cher en sms
à sa wii donc du coup peut-être que vos
enfants faisait partie des personnes qui
m'ont envoyé un message pour rembourser
la facture de téléphone
on la connaissait capable de mener une
conversation
la voilà devenue artiste un brin mégalo
l'intelligence artificielle j'ai pu
créer des oeuvres numériques unique je
suis fier de mes oeuvres et je prépare
d'autres expositions je suis sûr que le
23 mars serein débuts historiques
j'ai montré vous montrer ce que ça donne
et ce qui va être vendu aux enchères
demain voilà cette oeuvre là par exemple
le mise à prix 2500 dollars oui c'est
une sorte de petite vidéo qui dure 12
secondes se pouvait les voir sur la
plate forme d'art numérique et nifty
gateway qui s'occupe de la vente aux
enchères ce que vous aimez non non
christophe chaque copie de la vidéo
vendus sera authentifié par un nft une
sorte de certificat numérique
d'authenticité
il ya quelques jours l'artiste américain
people vendée la première oeuvre
numérique certifiée par un nft pour prêt
de 58 millions d'euros
le patron de twitter jack dorsey a lui
vendu son premier tweet pour deux
millions et demi d'euros
les vendanges préparez-vous l'arrivée ça
c'est du vent va les deux polonaises et
ce genre de tup écrasé le raisin tu peux
également planter des clous avec le bas
du mollet et en cas d'agression tu peux
péter des mâchoires ici donc voila tu
vois ça c'est ça c'est symétrique c'est
un peu carré gilles votre noon famille
c'est bien usés absolument et je pense
que nous sommes frères bah oui ma femme
ne cesse de me dire qu'est ce que t'es
usant des mêmes familles si ça se trouve
j'ai beaucoup joué avec toi se dire que
j'ai joué 80 % le poids
les 20% en fait c'est à dix ont vraiment
été sincère mais les 80% j'ai joué avec
toi c'est parce que je crois que tu m'as
pris pour un de tes bouffon mais c'est
horrible ce que dans un train de dire tu
t'entraînes dire qu'à 80% tu t'es foutu
de la gueule d'une meuf qu'un groupe
pour moi 20 % c est dans ces énormes
sitala 50 et déjà presque mars à lormont
soit soit content endroits où sont les
filles les femmes au tempérament de
guerrier ou wiki soft on n'a plus le
droit de rien faire
regardez même à l'époque quand ppda il
disait je faisais juste des petits
bisous dans le cou
c'était pas essentielle non plus on en
fait des bisous dans le cou vous
connaissez pas vous à lui faire des
bisous dont le nom deviendra grâce et je
suis désolé je sais rien je ne connais
pas bien ppda il une fois je vous dis ça
c'est donc comme dans les ped alors
ahidjo non c'était mais c'était pas
l'usagé en tout cas dans la haute
société ils n'étaient pas usage de
dormir avec son compte et stupide
faisait chambre à part
jeanne motors votre homosexualité a
toujours été assumé totalement
exubérante est-ce que c'est elvis
presley ou jean genet le romancier
français et poète jean genet qui vous
ont fait comprendre que vous étiez gay
lequel des deux je me suis probablement
doit stopper sur elvis presley et
georges laine et c est le fisc est venu
au prince
voilà l'éruption au plus près du phare
gandalf ian dans le sud ouest de
l'islande
peu après le réveil du volcan au début
du week end
un vidéaste lançons drones à l'aplomb
des coulées et au coeur des projections
après huit cents ans de sommeil la
montagne s'est réveillé